Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
made a sort of last minute at least as
far as it was announced visit to
Washington DC yesterday which included
an address to Congress a an opportunity
that not many foreign leaders get and we
will talk about that in a little bit the
speech that zielinski delivered to
Congress about the help that the U.S has
been providing to Ukraine in its
defensive War due to the invasion of
Ukraine by Russia and Vladimir Putin was
a good speech it was a powerful speech
and also the entire event had a pretty
weird feeling to it and I think I know
what the weirdness was and I'm going to
talk about that in a moment much fanfare
and we're going to get to all aspects of
this but a big Standing Ovation to kick
it all off
thank you
and what we're watching here if you're
watching today rather than listening is
zielinski entering too much Applause and
a standing ovation and the greetings of
so many different people there's Senator
Patrick Leahy and you see Charles
Schumer the senator uh and all sorts of
different people zielinski wearing his
typical
green I don't I don't know that I want
to editorialize the shade of green but
it is not the best shade not that we
really care about that it's just a weird
color
and here he greets uh vice president
Kamala Harris and then the Speaker of
the House outgoing Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi and he delivers a speech
and many Applause lines in the speech
including reminding the world in the
United States that Ukraine is not out of
this thing against
Against All Odds and doom and gloom
scenarios Ukraine didn't fall
Ukraine is alive
and Kicking
and another Standing Ovation there and
of course it is great that Ukraine has
been able to resist what some
characterized and handicapped as an easy
win for Russia when this started months
and months and closing in on a year ago
uh that is an absolutely great thing we
now get into the part that I believe was
the element of weirdness which is that
there was a feeling of this that it was
sort of okay we're gonna give you the
money new Aid package around 2 billion
including Patriot missiles we're gonna
do it but you've got to come here and
you've got to really thank us and you've
got to act extremely
solicitously towards us and that was
absolutely a big element of this speech
I'm glad to shred that President Biden
supported our peace initiative today
each of you ladies and gentlemen can
assist in the implementation to ensure
that America's leadership remains solid
bicameral
and bipartisan
thank you
and of course it is not actually
completely bipartisan and that's part of
what's interesting about this there are
people there are Republicans who are
sort of
soft supporters of the U.S helping
Ukraine and then there are people like
Matt Gates and Lauren bobert who
um are flat out just against American
help of Ukraine and they've sped into
the house chamber at the last minute and
sat there looking visibly bored never
clapping as a deliberate show of how
against this they are uh zelenski
assuring and reminding everyone in the
chamber that the money we are sending to
Ukraine is not charity it is part of uh
the goal shared goal of Global Security
and democracy Financial financial
assistance is also critically important
and I would like to thank you thank you
very much thank you for both Financial
packages you have already provided us
with and the ones you may be willing to
decide on your money is not charity
right it's an investment in the global
security and democracy that we handle in
the most responsible way
Financial financials okay and
um this ultimately led to a Ukrainian
flag actually being unfurled on the
floor of the house let this flag stay
with you lettuce and gentlemen
this flag is a symbol of our victory in
this war
We Stand we fight and we will win
because we are united Ukraine America
and the entire free world
okay so now what's happening is zelenski
is unfurling a Ukrainian flag which is
now being held up by Nancy Pelosi
um and vice president Kamala Harris
and then similarly you might see off to
the right of the screen that there is an
American flag in a triangle shape and
then that was handed to zelenski and off
he went with his American flag
and now this is the end of the speech
and we see zelenski leaving with his
American flag that was handed to him so
listen my feelings on this are very
mixed
of course I support Ukraine and of
course I believe that it is in the
interest of the United States and our
allies to beat back The Invasion by
Russia Putin's a lunatic authoritarian I
mean listen I've got a decade of
commentary on this there is absolutely
no question there
this entire visit
extraordinarily heavy on the theatrics
which I I feel repelled by the theatrics
to a great degree because it is such a
stage managed event
but public opinion particularly Global
public opinion depends on exactly that
stage management and so while I
personally find it off-putting as
someone who follows this stuff all the
time I have to be open to the idea that
for people who are busy working in
fields that are not political media
their opinion about what should happen
may actually be shaped by events like
this and maybe they want to see zelenski
come and grovel a little bit maybe
that's what they need in order to be
okay with or to continue seeing support
of Ukraine as a worthy cause now the
history of speeches like this to
Congress
during conflicts by world leaders of
other countries it's not the longest
list in the world
and we know of course of Winston
Churchill's address to Congress during
World War II as the prime minister of
the UK we know about
lekwaleza's address to Congress during
the Cold War as president of Poland we
know about Nelson Mandela's address to
Congress during the apartheid era
Mandela the first president of South
Africa and we have uh I may be missing a
couple but we have uh hovel's address to
Congress during the Velvet Revolution
the last the last and final president of
Czechoslovakia how does this compare
how does the situation in Ukraine
compare
not only on the facts but in terms of
its relation to the United States I
don't know that I have that answer and
it may require looking back from some
Future Point uh to really fully
understand that but a powerful speech
heavy on theatrics that I think was sort
of determined to be necessary
to continue
justifying to some degree in the court
of public opinion the support to Ukraine
that the United States continues to give
support which I widely am in favor of
while recognizing that those are dollars
for what is effectively speaking a proxy
war against Russia doesn't make it bad
uh in fact it's the right side this was
a war of aggression by Russia but much
more complicated than any simple
explanation